it's one of the most earthquake-prone
places on earth but even if you know
they're coming they're a powerful force
the evacuations in Chile began
immediately hospitals cleared of
patients with the fear of a devastating
rush of Pacific Ocean people told a head
for high ground in the coastal city of a
key K closest to the epicenter flames
the most obvious sign of the disruption
caused warnings and watches initially
spread along thousands of miles of the
South and Central American coastline
it's a seduction zone where you know 11
tectonic plate slides beneath another
that's where tsunamis do get caused it
because is very large earthquakes and
those typically generate tsunamis Chile
is a particular place where you know
historically there have been large
tsunamis generator in the past as i said
this particular part of the subduction
zone appears to have not experienced to
smell me for for over a hundred years so
that is somewhat unusual the shaking was
felt even in bolivia leaving a sense of
shock and in peru people and their pets
headed for safety the fear always of
aftershocks
in Chile dozens of small quakes over the
last few weeks had already put people on
edge and focused mines on emergency
plans the roads out of town were packed
but the country has learned a lot from
the devastating quake of 2010 which left
hundreds dead and a bill in the billions
the preparations could have made a
difference this time there is only so
much you can do in the face of the power
of nature ok well we know five people
dead let's get the latest situation
there we've got Greg Milam to bring us
up to date Greg yeah well we know the
the Government of Chile has ordered a
mass response by the military those
those forces mobilizing just to try to
bring some some sense of order and get a
grip of what exactly happened is of
course still nighttime there it may well
be daylight before they get a full sense
of exactly the damage that's been caused
but it seems as if the the fear of
tsunami has now focused purely on that
one area of Chile that those other areas
now not seen as being under threat and
the the water up to seven feet high
those waves as a result of that of that
tsunami we we know from certainly people
we've heard from in the aqui que area
who are returning to their homes there
is a sense that this is a place that is
more prepared maybe than anywhere in the
world for this kind of event people who
had warning of an earthquake a couple of
weeks ago that they all evacuated but
there was no tsunami then but they've
been packed they had their supplies
ready to get out as soon as those sirens
were heard and they did that and it may
well be those preparations have saved a
lot of lives and the fact that this is a
place that is well designed and has
plans in place to deal with just this
kind of eventualities